[Music]
love the way to bake with Kevin and Eman
the only show that takes you in the
kitchen gives you an dere make Jenny
we're not sure I'm can imagine what are
we going to cook today
and tangled you can you can telescope
cake for the birthday well you know
we're in the lootcrate kitchen before is
like taking special ingredients even our
dishes like an Iron Chef it's more like
ironic chef though because we get cool
fun things so we get on the picture here
looking double double chocolate chip
pancakes with Snickers syrup and peanut
butter whipped cream will it walk with
regret lieutenant Casey are made with
flour cocoa powder granulated sugar
baking powder salt baking soda egg
butter whole milk and semi-sweet
chocolate chip all right so here we have
the flour this all-purpose flour okay
sugar dump all that and it's all
pre-measured okay we have the bunches
goes look at the baking soda baking
powder and salt okay and you just start
and also let's not forget we have the
cocoa powder burns you up and this will
give a little white and this looks like
the last election now without a little
bit there with pancakes so white
[Music]
Megan breakfast great again all right
what do I do now so now I'm going to
make the wedding green which because the
eggs we have the buttering remember this
could be special about it
Humboldt butter if you will but right
over here can be urban deflected butter
that goes in there goes in the wet
ingredients go to whisk these all
together then we have the note
that's it man we beat these up a little
bit get mag on me dude
we're going to pour that right in there
and start mixing it around into the dry
and to the west gonna meet the dry
exactly right [ __ ] was so sexual
[Music]
this is generally what keeps me focused
use the mess like you think about I'm
gonna clean this [ __ ] up
and then I don't do it but you're
teaching me a better way today so blue
Krait catching people alright well that
looks pretty homogenized sir good hard
then the chocolate chips go in go inside
they do I think that's enough you can
just lay that thing right on the bowl
cuz the special in the bowl and take
your measuring cup this is eight oh this
is a majoring Cup
should I take 1/3 cup measure measuring
cup is unlikely MA yes alright so right
on right on then get those things on
there the pan is already hot we had to
turn it up to that halfway so it's a
medium love and how long does one
recommend cooking well you want to wait
till you see some bubbles okay and they
start checking the bottom with your
spatula that looks beautiful
nicely done on the flip except for a key
so whatever that ever does I didn't
stick the landing goodness right there
on that well I can't I haven't flipped
one perfectly yeah there's some smudge
on this it's like I don't even know how
to wipe properly you can tell by the way
I make pancakes
this makes perfect air correct you
should course [ __ ] you know target about
in three
so I lose the office whole guide all
right these are ready to come off let's
use an industry term with plate these
local
you know when you start using jargon I
can't follow you they look pretty good
let's do them in a stack got the idea
and I think that's the idea and then
we'll make it in fat stacks man let's
get you started on the so how do I do it
get the milk jug pour it into the pan
okay turn that on and we'll set it for
high yeah just to I get it to start
bubbling but then we're going to turn it
down as soon as it starts low so yeah
now I'm gonna walk over then we'll put
these kickers in and melt them and we'll
let it thicken up a little bit
me and the shut mouth I'm going to start
with Wi whipping the cream okay so the
first thing I want to do is get this
going with a pretty huge art and easy to
make mixer is it bubbling yes now I
think all the time of a seeming so once
you put in the copper oh it is bubbling
I'm just record sutures in there and
we'll put in the powdered sugar in here
so wait this milk and snickers make
secure so now we want to get whip this
until it's get this year's look a pretty
good and who should we played it it's
all brown with nothing
it really does look like the morning
after okay
right you were good pour that over there
try to keep the plate until it's about
how beautiful
it reminds me of that creature from
Dogma oh [ __ ] much yeah it is a little
gog office it's a whipped cream on their
dollop you tonight I'll buy that for a
dollar over boosters weddings I'm not
gonna let ya know here you go
right right and we're married yeah I
know you do me
by that he means major reward one thing
leads to another I could sum that cream
on top you know I like it good
all right in my mouth
[Music]
that's pretty good my god that was worth
the minutes of work I took a few mess I
was worth it Oh Lord
Oh Oh
good man I'm good yeah I love it
that early sucks and it lasted longer
that's fantastic man we learned
something useful right here in the
lootcrate kitchen how amazing is that
you want to see us cook other stuff
equally as appetizing comes to it yeah
it's [ __ ] stuff write to us on social
media man hit up near Andy on our
Twitter or Facebook Instagram or
anywhere
just make sure you hashtag it lootcrate
sake cares what I'd like you guys to
cook we'll cook it for you oh yeah
nothing if your suggestions are as good
as this we're going to be in business
here no doubt you want nuts in your
mouth come to me and Andy we'll look you
that's it for another wonderful edition
of wake and bake with Kevin Andy I'm
Kevin and I mean Bon Appetit
[Music]
you